-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
President Biden hosted
a state dinner tonight
for Australian prime minister
Anthony Albanese,
and the menu included
butternut squash soup
and roasted beet salad,
which is weird because
I was under the impression
that Australia was our ally.
[ Laughter ]
[ Australian accent ]
Beet salad?
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] The House
of Representatives voted today
to elect Louisiana congressman
Mike Johnson
Speaker of the House,
and apparently this
election result he will accept.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Republicans today
elected Mike Johnson
Speaker of the House.
Wow, the speaker race
was so embarrassing,
they're not even giving
their real names anymore.
Mike Johnson is the name
you give
when you check in to a motel
with your mistress.
That's what Spirit Halloween
calls their
Michael Jackson costume.
[ Laughter ]
During the second secret ballot
in last night's closed-door
Republican conference meeting,
former House Speaker
Kevin McCarthy
reportedly received
33 of the 34 votes
cast against Speaker designate
Mike Johnson.
Got to admit, it would have been
pretty funny if, after all this,
Republicans had landed
back on McCarthy.
Would be like matching
with your ex-wife on Tinder.
"What? We have a lot in common.
Our children, for example."
Trump 2020 campaign lawyer
Jenna Ellis
pleaded guilty yesterday
to a criminal charge
in the Georgia election case
and cried while expressing
regret for her actions.
Wow, pretty stark contrast
from her mug shot.
[ Laughter ]
This photo looks like
she also needed one
for her Christmas card
and didn't want
to make two stops.
[ Laughter ]
In his testimony yesterday
at former president Trump's
civil fraud trial,
ex-lawyer Michael Cohen said
whatever issues Trump had,
he "would bring it to me
in order to resolve,"
which explains why Cohen
always carried a plunger.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, that's funny.
A pest-control company
has unveiled its annual list
of the rattiest cities,
and New York City ranks third.
We came in third?
Who got -- Who got first place?
16th-century London?
[ Laughter ]
A new study suggests that the
moon is 40 million years older
than scientists
previously believed.
Even crazier, John Stamos is 60.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
nearly 1 in 4 adults
feel lonely,
and more often than not,
it's the drummer.
[ Laughter ]
Traffic on a highway in England
recently came to a stop
after an escaped pack of llamas
and alpacas
wandered onto the road.
Said frustrated drivers,
"Which ones are which?"
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
according to a new book,
McDonald's once tried to buy
the chain Panera Bread.
Wow, she spilled the tea
about everyone in that memoir.
[ Laughter ]
I told you that Panera thing
in confidence.
That was the monologue,
everybody.
We're off and running.